fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby it's President's Day
it is President's Day now real quick uh
for ten dollars can you tell me what
President's Day is because I can't and
I'm a history guy yeah it's where you
honor all the presidents of the United
States okay and you you eat their
favorite meals this is good so like for
Trump out of Diet Coke and three hot
dogs good I like this for Biden I had
um I had soup yeah soup and graham
crackers right this is great and then
for John F K I got some house this is
hoes house hoes can you look up what
President says here's what I'm gonna say
yeah what are we I'm gonna say
President's Day is the day we honor our
presence I said that that's all I know
and I think I'm wrong let's see what
President says hold on let me just guess
let me let me think what would be it's
acknowledging the president we're taking
we're taking it's a national holiday
meaning
yeah we're honoring our our the our
great leaders it's just like remember
when there used to be Columbus Day till
the woke took it with Columbus Day it
was just like yeah you're acknowledging
you're getting the day off because he
discovered Christmas Columbus came to
this country gave the Native American
smallpox and yes and and other diseases
and dirty blindness it belongs to us yes
his birthday is a U.S federal holiday
that okay I should know that celebrate
on the third Monday of February in honor
of George Washington the first president
United States increasingly the holidays
become an occasion to celebrate the
birthdays of both President George
Washington and Abraham Lincoln so I was
completely wrong so it's just to honor
those two presidents yeah but I have no
excuse I'm 56 and I'm a loudmouth when
it comes to All Things history and I
didn't know that school covers that I
don't think so you know why because the
classes matter
no I mean but George Washington
have you ever heard the story about how
George Washington
saved the Republic this is actually a
good time if you tell me cut down a
cherry tree so so he was he was very
formal and he always actually wanted to
be an actor people don't realize he was
very theatrical and an heir for the
theatrics like I got on my knees and I
prayed to our creator that we would
Prevail over the British he would tell
these he had these uh he worked about
his his speeches yeah so
there was the military After the
Revolutionary War was not getting paid
they were way back on their wages
because the fledgling government in
Washington DC couldn't get out of their
own way and they were fighting among
each other and everything else the way
the founding fathers wanted it was
disunity it was moving very slowly they
were like cobbling over whether these
guys should get this much money but
these soldiers including the bat brass
were [__] owed a lot of money they
were they didn't have any money to feed
their families they were like what is
this [__] I just fought for my country
you figure it out civilians figure it
out so they so they decide you know what
we'll figure this out this is what
military people do let's get our guns
let's go to the [__] capital okay
let's go to the Catholic and let's go
and [__] they stormed Jordan
Washington's house they go no they were
gonna go they were gonna go down to DC
into Congress where Congress was
deliberating and we're gonna go uh we're
gonna go things up because when we show
up with our guns
okay
take over the state it does the state
it's a French thing from the French
Revolution
so George Washington gets word of this
he gets word of this a sudden violent
unlawful seizure of power from the
government
now would you say that when the storm in
the capital was too right uh well
there's always been this sedition
there's always been the spirit in the
American Air
so
George Washington finds out that now
this is different these were people
those were civilians on January 6th this
was the news
they decided
Tim Kennedy were in trouble now is this
when real quick just the caveat is is
this George Washington before or after
he had those slave teeth put in this
would be after sir okay just I'm just
trying to paint Old Man painting the
picture yeah okay
here's the high White Sox and slave
teeth carry on
you got that you hear the visual yeah I
love it I love it so they're all he
finds out where they're all kind of
plotting to do this Washington shows up
now now Washington was even back then he
was the man everyone stopped to listen
to and he was always known for the guy
when the house is on fire
he'll be the calmest [__] in the
room he's Daddy he was Daddy he was the
sober voice and he was disciplined about
that like if you ever like somebody
shook his hand and clasped it with the
other hand he looked at him like excuse
me there's a formal way to do [__] yeah
that's not it yeah there's a there that
rigid discipline that that British slash
that was that was everything so
he apparently walks up to speak
and he takes out his spectacles
and kind of labors them onto his face
his bifocals to read his speech and he
says forgive me gentlemen
I have grown quite blind in defense of
my country oh wow meaning nobody had
suffered more than that [__]
he'd suffered right with him he'd Frozen
he'd starved he'd fought and all that so
apparently he gives this long speech
about how this is how it's supposed to
be this is how government is supposed to
be slow plotting because if it gets too
fast people take it over people
down there though I don't know how's it
going but the bottom line is the bottom
line is they say that's how he saved the
Republic remember when George the first
in in England who had fought the
Revolutionary War they said we'd like to
make you King they wanted to make George
Washington king I remember this like
yesterday and he said I did not fight a
revolutionary war so I could be George
II yes I'm a president and I serve at
the Leisure of the people I'm glad you
reminded us of this dude damn it guys I
remember this yesterday this is why by
the way how many people have turned
their how many people have been like wow
Brian's doing history again we're just
gonna go to another one we're gonna find
another
well the Brian Kelly show I have a lot
of obscure academics that nobody's heard
about in it and they zoom in hasn't been
going very well for me and they zoom in
first of all it's bad enough no one
knows of them and you're talking
nobody's heard of them but beat then
there's nothing worse than a zoom I had
a physicist on who was talking about how
Plato was right and Einstein was wrong
and I he was talking in math terms and I
couldn't follow any of it then you're
lost now now I'm gonna be my dad with me
you having fun though no I am fun no I'm
not that's what my dad says yeah anytime
I'm like oh I don't want to do this he's
like cool you haven't find them
well see the thing is Brian decided to
have a a podcast called the Brian
Collins show instead of having comedians
on and other things I'll have academics
you've not heard about but I'll read
their books okay and then you get all
excited and then they zoom in and it's a
little fuzzy sometimes oh no yeah hey
let me ask them what having fun though
the one thing the bride is not good at
is coming up with a podcast concept and
then really going for it I don't know
why you don't run through daddy here I
should run it through Daddy because I
have because I know you're being nice
and you don't look at the numbers but I
looked them in numbers I don't care
about numbers I'm sorry are you having
fun
it's about the experience you're no I I
know but I flew to Appleton Wisconsin
two years writing a script didn't sell
it do you have fun though did you
what did you learn though good
experience you you can't either
I've lost 15 pounds of psoriasis not fun
though have fun they're fun I do I had a
blast in Naples though oh tell me about
that you know I got it I got we take a
little break B can we take a break and
talk about accents we've been in and
also give our dates because listen I get
a busy week I'm at The Comedy Store
Wednesday Thursday Bakersfield there you
go with 30 seconds left one show
beautiful Bakers one night only
Bakersfield and then Pasadena the ice
house is back dude you know this oh yeah
they re-re-did it they redid it put a
lot of money into it the Lakers now own
it all right really so Ice House yeah
the bus family owns the ice house they
redid it your boy's there shopping
friends the first one and it's me Trevor
Wallace Adam Ray that's Saturday night
10 p.m show that thing's almost sold out
the VIP take story sold out so get your
tickets as you're listening to it right
now then Brea California March 3rd one
night two shows because March 4th of a
Cowboys fight campaign for Jon Jones
return UFC 285 jelly roll Rampage
special guest oh Oklahoma City March 9th
through 11th Tacoma March 23rd 25th get
your tickets but Ice House Bakersfield
and Brea you're up next give it to him B
listen you're going up north like a
little penguin I'm a little penguin
because Alberta Canada apparently is
very cool but I will be there February
23 24 25 comic strip come to the comic
strip and I'm at Zanies Nashville March
two to four get your tickets Sony Hall
New York City come on man why are we not
sold out yet March 11th Sony Hall one
show only March 11th New York City and
then I come right back to New York West
Nyack New York about 32 minutes outside
are you working my birthday huh oh yeah
dude really my birthday March 16 17 18.
you might be doing a fight companion
then um I might spend my birthday Mr Joe
Rogan oh man
then mine's Fest in Austin Texas mine's
best at the Vulcan gas company April
15th Tim Poole Bill ottman a whole bunch
of other people Destiny
um it's going to be some really
interesting people and we're gonna have
a uh I guess just a podcast and all
kinds of stuff so come come learn are
you doing stand up there too or uh no
just doing a podcast that'd be cool yeah
I'll tell you what's not cool dude when
you get in the accent like I had this
girl texting him driving the lanes were
going oh yeah I see her looking down
runs right in the back of me it's about
two years ago I went oh I'm screwed yeah
but then there's Morgan and Morgan okay
what is that because sometimes you get
injured in an accident sometimes
something happens you're out of work and
how do you get compensation and some
good luck trying to go through your
insurance oh dude my grandma was at a
famous rib joint and they were doing
construction slipped walked into the
bathroom broke her hip okay and I went
what do we do granny yeah you're out of
a hip right I didn't have money back
then right what are we gonna do well now
picture Grandma's driving and somebody
hits her she gets Whiplash and she's in
some real trouble and she has a necklace
on see she has no money this is what
happens well Morgan and Morgan hold up
you talking about the Morgan Morton the
official Law Firm partner of the UFC I
am oh my God tell us more well you can
file a claim from your phone in eight
steps this is insane on order for for
takeout this is insane no listen so so
what it is is basically
um at the end of the day there are
probably I have 800 lawyers they're the
largest injury Law Firm over a hundred
offices Nationwide they've collected
over 15 billion dollars recovered for
clients now a lot of times when I think
of suing somebody I'm thinking about
suing somebody and I don't like that
yeah Sue a person yes you're suing an
insurance company yes that's what you're
doing they're covered to make yourself
whole and also here's the thing about
Morgan Mormon their fee is free unless
you win Morgan Morgan's fights for the
people and not for the powerful give
them something all right that's why
Morgan Morgan's giving away two tickets
to UFC 285 March 4th in Las Vegas to see
Jon Jones Sarah gone if you can't make
that make sure you tune into the fight
campaign on thick Boy network that's
right they will be sending a lucky
winner and a guest to Las Vegas to watch
UFC 285 live to learn more about enter
this contest just go to UFC Morgan
ufc.com that's Morgan ufc.com spider uh
uh to win two tickets to UFC 285 no
purchase necessary Sweepstake ends on
February 21st 2023 open a residence in
48 U.S states and the DC ages 18 and
older please can't be young void we're
prohibited for official rules visit
Morgan ufc.com again go to Morgan
ufc.com fighter to win two tickets to
UFC 285. now let's get back to the
filthy program how about first of our
boy Eric at Virginia the Virginia's
Restaurant Virginia
first of all
700th Street Gustavo Gustavo is his
partner in crime I love those [__]
guys and then did you did you meet the
giant Italian guy
there's a town and he's six eight his
grandfather was the heavyweight champion
of the world
I did not mean oh yeah I'm sure he was
there you talking about
you talking about hey the only Giant in
all of nape shaved head
sure I think father times is Barbara
okay older guy older guy no I did not
mean I mean literally six eight I did
not hands the biggest dick beaters
you've ever seen really and then he was
he was doing this to me he's like my
grandfather oh my God who's your
grandfather and we looked him up and
holy [__] most knockouts ever have you
ate 72 what he was six eight six nine
like the twenties okay like yeah no
shitty didn't lose we were fighting he
was just and he goes he wouldn't forget
a box him but if he landed it yeah
he's fighting white dudes who are 130
pounds yeah but the food we had there
was stupid especially for my diet you
know I'm on Carnivore so you're talking
about the the freaking T-Bones the
fillets and then we're there every night
I'm there for lunch dinner every single
night and then he won't let his pay
drives me nuts and then uh the next day
is hey I'm thinking for your last name
I'm thinking like burgers I went
Oh okay that's cool yeah that's fine
burgers are cool are you skimping a
little bit though right burgers and he
goes no no dude trust me yeah bro
he brought it out and he's like I
brought the bun you should have a bun I
know because your skin your psoriasis
but it's the best burger you've ever had
no forget Burger it's the best thing
that's ever touched these large lips
yeah that I got from my daddy yeah they
are they it was I I was unbelievable I
couldn't talk yeah
I believe there he goes come on what are
we doing come on yeah and the whiskeys
he had there too well he'll open up some
wines one last day I was there well I I
when I think of Naples now and I think
of off the hook Comedy Club I just think
about Eric and that restaurant listen
I'm never not there I love Naples
they've had a Resurgence and they're
doing their thing used to be a tough
Club back in the day now it's different
right they've had Bill Burr their Ron
White you yeah it's a different animal
now
but that the club's fine club's Great
Captain Brian they're great but I don't
know if if I would be at Naples if if I
didn't meet Eric I wouldn't go back
although I love Naples I could live in
Naples yeah the only only problem is now
it's booming right all the people from
New York are moving down there so that's
booming some money property value stupid
some money 60 well 60 million dollar
houses some money right some money 60
million it's 65 million dollars my skin
does great in the weather I can breathe
finally there yeah the hurricanes have
been an issue right once a year you get
a bad hurricane get a boat you need a
boat because Noah because you got to be
like Noah you got to have a boat on hand
the house is you hit a button that come
with things that protect it okay if it's
close to the beach so you can figure it
out yeah my problem is is it's whatever
I'm not Aegis but there's so many old
people it'll make you sad yeah like me
and my brother any restaurant walked
into I was like holy [__] happens
waiting for matinee Heaven's waiting
room right I mean yeah they have one
foot in the grave everywhere you go
it'll bum you out yeah good for you yeah
but also you're making me sad couldn't
be more Republican couldn't remember
which is why things are run so well yeah
which is why the streets are super clean
yes there's literally I was talking to a
cop and uh he's like I came from Pueblo
Colorado yeah not the bad area Pueblo's
hoodie and uh they have biker gangs and
all the cartel trafficking drugs up
there awful awful City and he goes yeah
I've transferred from Pueblo to here I'm
like oh [__] I go dude where the
homeless singers
six months he was
[__] I didn't mention I don't even think
about it yeah there's two yeah he was
and I know him Dave and Ryan dude yep
how's it going with this nice guys I was
like are they like legit homeless he's
like yeah he's like this is there's lots
of money in crypto or something instead
of being homeless or what's going on and
he's like I don't know nice guys yeah
he's like but he's like they're not drug
addicts they're just wind up you gotta
have a couple hobos they're just two
that's what I call hobo but they're not
on the main parts like you know you go
down a nice like San Vicente of
Brentwood they're homeless everywhere
they like stay under the bridges yeah
it's crazy yeah yeah that that's uh
that's I know it's not compassionate but
it's a little bit better when you don't
have needles everywhere because you know
like Portland and Seattle
um they've ruined those cities in San
Francisco amazing compassion and
services yeah where's that going for
them yeah it's going great tourism oh
yeah everybody leaves I could live in
Naples I was telling that the gym like I
could live here it's just get rid of
some of the olds you know well they they
are on a rotating they're on a rotating
belt and that's going to be you and I I
hope someday buddy yeah when you're
older eating for coffee yeah yeah huh
nothing to do well I don't know why I
say you and I although my biological age
I just had this whole [__] insane
checkup well they tell you insane
checkup yeah and uh I got some issues
did they tell you you're gonna die
you're gonna die at 44. cholesterol is
high
my biological age and I don't they you
don't put too much strength in this but
if you look at all the markers
apparently I'm 45. yeah not bad not
young but yeah not young not even say
like 27 something no no glitch dude only
50. testosterone's good Propecia though
are you you're back on it no no I'm not
because that'll tend to raise your
Estuary yeah you always go off and on it
yeah Daddy's going to go bald and
doesn't care because he's going to keep
his testosterone yeah I'd rather have
testosterone than here dude where buy a
wig and get this that dick still Pops I
don't know how long I've told you this
Daddy's daddy's dick pops that's never
been a problem for me I'd rather have a
good dick than good hair yes 100 all day
100 also you want your testosterone
yeah as soon as your testosterone I was
hoping I was hoping my test was low so
should I get on test yeah no it's better
that's high naturally that's the best
gift God can give you yep I was like
listen here knows not his thing but
testosterone did you say Aaron Aaron
knows yeah you have a giant nose like
when God was going out noses he's like
yeah give him a little bit I know he's
give a little bit extra yeah
you know I looked at my entire family
my entire extended family
no you're not gonna be in fashion shows
you know this though right well I'm No
One's Gonna Be a model I got I got some
of the Symmetry I mean I'm I'm you know
I'm the best looking one that you could
make an argument for the fact that I'm
oh I win that argument I'm right up
there but you know I was like okay yeah
it's all right it's kind of bumped up
okay yeah some people have beautiful
family oh I know where they're just
gorgeous yeah well you come down to go
down that [__] Manhattan Beach or go
go see what those oh you go to certain
parts those D1 families those those
professional athletes go to Miami like
what the [__] the hell is happening here
[__] Miami man dude how about uh
Tiger's birthday Tiger's birthday is
tomorrow but we threw his birthday party
yesterday so I took the red eye make his
birthday party freaking Theo shows up
he's not you know he's never missed
Tiger's birthday deal Vaughn never
missed Tiger's birthday that's that
Jesus Christ
[Laughter]
um how is Gordon Ryan there he is I
can't believe Theo showed up he's never
missed his birthday oh that's so cool
yeah he's never missed it that's great
oh I love little freaks so hilarious
I bet you Theo would be a great dad I
told him that and then you know what's
funny is he uh how's he doing he's good
he's great he's here and he just chose
at The Improv through and Friends wish I
could do him but I was on the road and
then he uh you know the moms and there's
some hot moms and he's just you know
doing his thing they don't know who he
is he's you know feels funny all the
time all the time and he's like hey
how's it going he's like uh I'm not I'm
not like a pedophile enough I'm with him
I know him I know he's like I know hit I
don't know him but I know his kids and
they're like what and I was like oh no
he's just like that yeah I'm not with it
I'm not with him but I know I'm friends
with his kids and that's being all
awkward yeah it was so funny though I
was laughing my ass off and they were
just like what the [__] he said I'm not
pedophile man and they're like excuse me
I was like no I'd like to get him back
he's a comment oh he's the best is he
around he leaves Thursday where
back to Nashville so he's splitting this
time yeah he still has his Studio out
here Nashville March 2nd the fourth is
he gonna be around then I don't know man
I don't know his goddamn all right I'm
not his assistant
I was hoping to do something with
Michael Chandler but I think he's doing
the he's doing tired
he's doing yeah he's doing tough yeah
how was Gordon Ryan what's that what was
that it was great yeah have I not seen
you since Gordon no I haven't no all
right well I just want to know what it
was like he's just such he's a shot yeah
is he training is he still because he
talked I'm thinking about well I'm sorry
he he's the best in the world he's a
huge basket look at the size of him go
back he's not that big
he looks bigger than you there but I
mean he's 220 pounds bro okay yeah I'm
about 30 pounds isn't that funny yeah
what's your p's and q's you guys look
the same there now don't roll with them
never right he wanted to and I said let
me get my schedule all booked Gordon
Ryan
it's Gordon Ryan
let's buy those glasses all right now
listen
but he was talking about on Rogan how he
has stomach issues and he's kind of
staff for a long time uh he has like
this word fungus yeah well he had staff
well staff is another thing and then the
answer
well it's that but then there's like he
has this weird rare fungus so how does
he how do you get rid of that he's
constantly has to live with it so what
what they tell him though is there a way
to get no he he takes this medication
but it's just something he's gonna have
to deal with the rest of his life what
it stays in his body such a good so that
that's how good he is so he's fighting
not only against the best Jiu Jitsu guys
in the world but also his own body he's
never 100 he's always around 80 85 he
says on his good days about 85 that's
how talented that [__] what do you he
just signed a seven-figure contract with
flow sport too wow wow he's just sick
all the time
oh my God and he said he's never been
sick of them when he did Rogan for the
first time and he said I didn't he goes
I didn't know really all the time so I
didn't want to cancel my cats my tummy's
upset he's probably like oh never see
you again [__] badass man yeah such a
stuff what such a nice mind such a nice
guy great dude strong mind great great
yeah what is that would you tell me this
where uh maybe it's Jamie Foxx talking
about if you have if you think you have
problems and you look at other people
who have all this everything's going
great for them if you put all your their
problems if they put their problems on
the floor you put your problems on the
floor you might take all your problems
to run the [__] home run the [__] out of
there yeah you never know everybody's
struggling with something oh yeah
everybody in their own way [__] that's
one of the worst things though he's
constantly nauseous then on the show
because he can't he has to eat kind of
like I do but then he ordered a
cheeseburger I'm like dude if you I had
anxiety I text him that more the next
morning at 4am I was like hey how you
feeling he said I'm fine dude this is
new medication we can eat regular food
now because usually has to be very
careful what he eats because of stomach
the kid's a [__] Savage man damn such
a such a nice guy such a nice dude
wow all right guys that's our time we'll
see you later you got Jake Paul and uh
Tommy Fury fighting Sunday yeah that's
uh we're doing a Cowboys fighting pen
that's this Sunday 11 A.M
damn
I'll be in Edmonton but I'm coming back
I could have made it if I'd been smart
um your thoughts on Tommy Fury easy
fight for uh Jake it's a perfect matchup
easy fight yeah if you've seen Tommy
fight before it's a tough night really
there's a reason why Jake's been chasing
around the freaking continent running
how long has Tommy Fury been fighting uh
he has eight fights he has two more
fights Than Jake he's undefeated the
record of his first five or four
opponents is what is it it's uh it's
it's 12 and 150 yeah horrible he found a
guy who was who was like five in a
hundred yes embarrassing it's so bad
good looking kid yeah great looking kid
I don't think he's still doing it yeah I
don't know what that means Brian but
he's he's doing what fighting I guess
he's breathing yeah there's no no he
kudos to him no he's putting on he's
putting on his gloves and getting in the
ring dude who gives a [__] did he have
fun though did you have fun though
after I get knocked out by no goon did
you have fun though I didn't absolutely
absolutely not yeah but good experience
right right life lessons and that's fun
that's fun right there's always when you
look back on it it'd be fun be fun for
you right right
um no but you know he he it's a perfect
star matchup for Jake he struggles with
like power punchers to dirty boxes Jake
all day he has good footwork and good
fundamentals with Jake and eat them
alive I think Jake gets it gets them out
there on the floor really yeah unless
Tommy decides to run okay yeah it's a
great I don't know I haven't seen him
it's a great matchup for Jake yeah like
he struggled against a guy who had named
T-Rex he's this MMA fighter with small
arms you know not the highest level
fighter and that guy you want the
decision hold on and he's strong is that
a real thing
and he went to decision with him and I
think the most he's fought is five
rounds like Jake's done eight rounds
with Anderson Silva even though he's a
power puncher he still has cardio just
fight eight rounds eight rounds and and
Jake Jake goes yeah and he dirty he gets
dirty like he's gonna [__] Tommy Fury up
my son so you know I teach my son boxing
I watch tutorials so much fun it's my
favorite thing to do yeah you're a
YouTube coach I'm a YouTube yeah
um most dads are though yeah but I you
know I know a couple things yeah teach
them how to kick you know stuff like
that and um it's always a struggle
because he's just like oh come on dad
but he's getting really good he's
throwing he likes it he's just getting
good he's like learning how to move his
body and then you see somebody who
doesn't know how to do that and he's
like damn I go you're better than he is
yeah my these two adults friends of mine
came in I don't have a box neighbor I
was holding this for them and they you
know you know he is yes you know
um and uh it was funny because he was on
the scooter I was letting him drive up
and down my driveway and these two kind
of older kids like a Razor scooter the
little ones but uh no it was one of
those electric ones but yeah so um
these two kind of
older kids you know kind of Ruffians in
the name it's Manhattan yeah
um they kind of they got on there they
got on their bikes and they ride out and
my son kind of almost gets he kind of
goes whoa no like that because he saw
them he's kind of he gets scared and the
kid goes [__] you oh wow it keeps going
Jesus Christ damn my son goes that kid
just said [__] you to me
why'd he do that I I it was for the
first time he was like but I was having
such a nice day and he was just mean to
me and it scared him it made him sad
welcome to the internet yeah hurt his
feelings that's a bummer and but no but
I went but then um
then he was like
well they're just going off because I
hate them I go take it easy go get them
and all of a sudden yeah all of a sudden
he goes he goes he goes
well they're bigger but I want to punch
them in the face and I go well that
might be why I'm teaching you how to you
use your hands do you say how bad do you
hate them prove it do it prove it to
Daddy right now or you're not eating
dinner he starts [__] hitting the Bob
he starts hitting the bag he starts
[__] he's like oh he didn't chase him
down oh well they were already way long
gone they were long gone but if they
live in the neighborhood now I'll see
you again yeah that's what I said now
he's like he's literally he's like he
wanted to hit mits again I'm like what's
going on how old were these kids though
they were like they're all they're two
grades older one kid's three grades
that's a huge big difference bigger
there they see how they're just me son
might get beat up but did you have fun
did you have fun though do you have fun
do you learn you get your face kicked in
you're losing you got your teeth you got
to taste the real world yeah now he's
going oh I got to build some ammunition
unfortunately that's the real world
people suck dude well it's just there's
always a threat you're gonna have a
great day and somebody can come along
just [__] your day up but you never had
a bad day did you have fun can't find
out fun you work your whole life with a
business somebody sues you for no reason
yeah
[Music]
but with your son it's uh yeah it's just
you know it's the way it goes the way it
goes Bob that's where he goes and here
that kid said [__] you things at home
are not great buddy uh correct like he's
already losing correct for him to just
lash out and go [__] you that trust me
that kid is hurting well that's what I
said yeah I said something's going on
there the kid's parents suck buddy yeah
that's all it is yeah [__] you
no reason I was just going why'd he do
that he was so confused and then he got
angry you know he got scared he got
upset because the world sucks yeah and
then he got they have to learn the hard
way then he got angry you know Daddy has
a temper
now I'm nice yeah then I I I I want to
switch I'll kill you you should have
said you want to see someone hurt your
feelings come read Daddy's comments oh
yeah yeah oh yeah I wish [__] you
thought we got yeah yeah that's that's
it right yeah
he'll get used to it though yeah well no
it's just the world it's all right
it's fine yeah I mean what are you gonna
do good the kid sucks he's already
losing the kids already lost he didn't
he doesn't need his ass my sons is hard
to [__] you though sometimes you deserve
it but not for just going by all right
he's a little wobbly don't be [__]
maybe almost crashed into him yeah he's
a little wobbly sometimes the Hate's got
some legitimacy to it [__] it you know I
know with that young just another kid
nah sometimes I would have told him [__]
hey don't be wobbly on your bike [__]
you on your scooter [__] wobbly don't
wobble at me if he was headed their way
I get it sometimes just people you just
want to be a dick sometimes you're just
like ah you're a weak link you [__]
wobbly tighten up well that's probably
what they say they probably saw
weaknesses smaller yeah now my son now
you know what made myself a little
tougher he said I can't be that wobbly
you just don't watch it
oh
100 yeah wrestling I'd like him to
wrestle
yeah all of this for him I'll do Jiu
Jitsu as I said earlier right wrestling
you have a tough kid gotta have a You
Gotta Have I love you but you know I
don't know if the calendars are made for
that world well I was you were for what
but I was wrestling now I have that
temperament yeah yeah I I think I I
think I would say I have that
temperament I was you know yeah I don't
know if my son he might be a little
sensitive that's okay though right yeah
yeah another one's made to Restless
different temperatures as tough as you
get I mean wrestling's the you know
wrestling kids teach them some lessons
but I'd rather have those skill sets
than boxing you know I think the reason
I respect wrestlers so much is when I
was in high school I went to Dan Gables
Camp yeah like they just train you quote
unquote like that with the Hawkeyes yeah
and I was like
that's the craziest [__] like that D1
[__] that program where they make you
run sprints for an hour in the morning
and then remember those are kids so
that's just a taste of it it's not the
real big league those those Iowa the
Hawkeyes they're there at 5 30 in the
morning and they're [__] wrestling
and then you wrestle again after that
maybe all major division one sports it's
your number one job it's all you major
in that yeah that's it and they're
getting paid now
yeah but that's such a different thing
like
yeah that's that's just unless you've
done it don't say it no it's a beast
super beast yeah
super beast you know you're you're two a
days you want to wrestle twice a day God
oh yes three days and then three years
then you got lifting yeah it's nuts yeah
you're up at four
it's a different Animal Man
Soul numbing right depending it's just
you're like you're almost like a robot
yeah it's just what you do it's what you
signed up for
how many people dropped off in
percentage-wise 90 years tons
like so many people I've played D1 but
they played for a year played D1 but
they played for yeah it doesn't count
yeah yeah if you don't finish the four
don't tell that's how long she got
drafted in the NFL
that's another thing that's like that's
what I mean it's like
I think what you respect with all of
that stuff whenever you see somebody is
you if you had if you had a taste even
in high school and you saw the guys that
went on or just if you in your life you
push yourself you know and you see
people that can do it for that long and
get to the top of that that's why you
have respect for them that's why
reverence is important okay but my thing
is that when you don't have respect for
that when you don't take a minute just
to honor it or say it that's society and
then put yourself in that category
that's a sign in a nutshell yeah but
when but because it's because you never
you never
even walked in the room they don't have
a perspective but they have opinions on
it yeah but you're not you're not even
the same Lane Daddy but that's it that's
the Internet
it's like dude you can't but in anything
like like you see like so somebody was
dissing um
[__] who was it uh I got a story for you
somebody who's disting Dustin Justin
Timberlake okay and I was like now hold
on now hold on dude I don't know if you
know but he can sing anything you think
he can sing like what you're seeing him
saying is fine but he's a very talented
[__] and I stayed at the top of
his field that's that's not an accident
that's a lot of work somebody owns a
billion dollars from his voice
somebody sir you're late on your payment
on your sky on a friend of mine a friend
of mine got such a kick out of this I go
he goes shab shaba can start shop still
kick ass and I go what do you mean and
he goes I mean like for a regular guy
like you know somebody like somebody
like me who's a purple belt if I came
out
and I go like this I go we'll see what
you have to understand is that it's I'm
surprised you're asking this because no
he couldn't beat you up he could [__]
you and I said that and there was a
silence there was there was a long pause
and I just and I realized he was
laughing so hard oh he was yeah you just
hear him
and it was just so [__] he was just
it was so funny to him he was like God
damn he's all so aggressive
that's kind of true though then he went
on he went on for five minutes what's he
do just Jitsu his approval he's a doctor
oh I would
yeah yeah yeah no no he he got it he's a
high that would be like
in his field and what he gets it like he
gets it he's been around Pro stupid
question but yeah no no he was talking
about I'll be like me like hey man you
mind if I should do the open heart
surgery and I watched it a little bit
Yeah if I jump in there you're but you
haven't you haven't trained in a long
time so I had to be completely honest
with you right now to be completely
honest that doctor no I'm training crazy
doctor I don't know if it's a move you
heard of like a scarf choke right yeah
you know I could literally take my dick
and wrap it around his neck and choke
well that's not that long so no but no I
do it like you're making me angry with
it I do it like this that hurts yeah it
hurt both of us I might tap yeah you
might tap yeah either way tap yourself
yeah yeah
you're trimmed up with the with the uh
[__] Carnival well it's helping my I
mean look at my skin the face the old
yep the old face isn't swollen less
drinking are you drinking oh oh here oh
you're still doing that that flares no
that doesn't flare my surprise it's
breads yeah that's why that's why I told
our boy uh wheat I I don't eat that [__]
anymore no no no no no sugars not none
of those carbs stuff like that that's
flares I told Eric I was like this
burger is worth getting spots on my face
sometimes you got to push it but Daddy
Daddy's cholesterol well daddy lives on
on aged cheese as you know you're still
doing the cheese no not anymore there's
no sugar there's no booze I'm going ham
dude I'm gay where's my face no no no
change yet no change nothing yet it
takes it takes a while done that I'm
pretty washed out yeah it takes a while
let your body kind of settle everybody
settle
the baby fat sits in your face
yeah
baby hat
well great well that's our time that's
our time all right what do you got Jen
wait is anybody on that card
no no
why would they do that I love Luke if
you're Logan why would you do it because
it's as long as he's not trying he's out
there doing it I mean he's not trying no
I mean he's not like Jake what about
Jake Luke rockhold I don't have thoughts
on it
because I don't think it doesn't make
sense why they would do it it'd be great
for Luke and they would there's no
upside to the Paul brothers fighting
Luke says Savage Savage it's just and
he's big yeah like he fought at 205
different you think they're gonna fight
that fight and for what yeah why would
they do that that's a real challenge but
they're also going for the Connors and
Nate Diaz's door they're not going for
Luke I love Luke with the I don't have
thoughts on there's no way that's
happening okay
yeah
what do you got Jim all right the first
one did you watch The Last of Us
you watched last week's I did not I've
only watched the first episode I'm sorry
Apple it's almost have lives I was like
Jesus Christ I said on Sunday night
though you can't chill on a Sunday I'm
obsessed with uh physical 100 that
Korean show oh American Idol's back
yeah I didn't know that I didn't see the
pro promotion if you'd like physical 100
because I was thinking about you me and
Jay watched it what'd you think it's
good yeah I'm not obsessed with like
everybody else
but and I guess it got spoiled because
of uh akiyama sexyama didn't think
because he lost I guess
[Music]
um
no if you follow if you if you follow
him in any capacity he posted about and
spoiled it all right he's so awesome
smart guy though and a real leader yeah
he's stunned super stud half Korean half
Japanese yep he has two different names
he has Yoshi hero akiyama and chusang
Hoon I think yeah
Korean side whenever chin only likes one
side whatever he fights he always has
like a patch of Korea's flag and a patch
of Japan he was like I think his dad's
Japanese right I think so yeah that's uh
that's pretty wild yeah he's a stuff
he's very revered in Korea that's for
sure he's famous he's super oh yeah
outside of all the dudes singing and
sells out like everything what yeah he
does what I love about that is he puts
himself out there like when you see him
in physical 100 he's putting himself out
there like any dress as well like his
style his style is 46 years old he's
he's a super competitor that's what he
is dude you know who's in shape is uh
Bert Kreischer post a picture with him
Wade Boggs and uh Mike also with the
shirt off Mike alstott for his age is
Jack dude shredded
let's see boy I'm ugly no you're not
Brian what are you talking about that's
you younger
all right oh that's a thing by the way
Bert Kreischer how about this uh my who
is the comic he's a comic he's tutor of
them might be ran a marathon with
Chrysler Chrysler did Chrysler smoked
him Mickey Mantle jeans [__] dude he's
he's strong I want uh I was talking to
bird about doing a tough mudder with me
he's a [__] tough dude
him and Joe Coy have been doing this
tour bus thing which is
awesome as well keep going you'll see
it's just three white dudes
my call Scott no there it is bottom
right yeah it'll go through that's his
mom and dad he says the first time his
dad seem to stand up what his kicks are
ridiculous there
right there look at my gas thought wow
what a stud yeah right who's the guy in
the middle that's Wade Boggs that's Wade
Boggs yep okay
um
yeah no but um how old is Austin
Mike what a stud
[__] and Bert with the born and raised
kicks they're not even out yet 49 years
old shredded yeah he's he's he's just
yeah right yeah
[__]
not not as tall I guess six one maybe
six yeah just big old arms
um yeah sixth one how long did he play
for hot second Hall of Famer wow
all right what do you got Jim
all right the first one are boy jelly
he's going on tour in 2023 and he has a
bunch of like first of all it's his tour
but they're joining him I guess so I
don't I just I literally saw the
announcement this morning I think he
posted on his Twitter was like going on
it's called I forget the name of the
torch I'm born on the back road back
road baptism yeah but Ashley McBride who
just won a Grammy with Carly Pearce
that's huge Chase Rice is huge he's
getting yeah he's definitely getting Big
Three Six Mafia yellow wolf it's kind of
crazy dude that's yellow that was my
name
dude the gray wolf tour oh
um
[Music]
it's just you in Naples
and uh I can't show this video but
that's them winning the Grammy that's
actually McBride is the one on the right
with the guy she's gone she's got some
who's the one with the ink and the
that's that's Ashley McBride that's
who's gonna tour with uh jelly oh wow
she's a um
yeah you can see her nipples here which
we can't show we don't [__] around yeah
she's so talented too is she super
talented so talented it's a hell of an
eagle and everything there's a lot of
stuff a lot to take in there
in a great way a lot to take yeah that's
a lot to take in buddy it's a mouthful
more than a mouthful more than mouth
that's a while that's a lot buddy
so this guy he he's trying to come
become viral I don't know about a lot of
his videos that guy on here this guy
yeah his name is Joey Smith told me
about him yeah okay so it's great some
of them I I looked at you know I wanted
to make sure I look at a bunch of videos
and see what's going on yeah some do
seem a little to in my opinion a little
white knightish but not too much so
anyways but a lot of videos they put out
is good you should get them on the
podcast actually let me see it so cool
so this right here right so you know
girls these days in gyms they'll film
themselves and they'll say that there's
creepers there's guys looking at them
and yet they're in a thong and like yeah
tripoli's post about that no
Sam is Instagram go to yeah go to go to
Sam's Instagram for a sec
it's so funny
I mean I don't know if he's been banned
yet but just scroll down and I'll show
it to you it's so [__] funny is that
one the far right one no no keep going
keep going keep going keep going post a
lot you post [__] a lot oh wait wait
go back
uh no I'm sorry uh keep going go up or
down down down down down
slowly like how old is it bro it's not
too old
it's not too old it's oh that right
there oh my God my gym has so many
creeps starter pack
this is so true oh my God my gym
just camel toe [__] eyeliner you know
Calvin Klein bra and crazy yeah but
that's fine if they want to do that but
to film it and then say people are
creeps by they're doing it just reviews
of course exactly so that's what that
guy can you imagine this so this is what
Joyce won't
even say the name is funny but Joyce
will put this up
uh turn the music off and then see the
guy the girls he just literally glances
one for like a millisecond man does
nothing wrong again there is a huge
difference between somebody being legit
creep and simply glancing or looking at
somebody this man is standing next to
the machine that is using waiting to hit
set while his partner goes he looks left
he looks right and he looks damageable
wondering what you're doing that's
normal not to mention you're directly in
front of him with this giant ball with
the camera pointed directly at him
filming him and what you're doing for
the entire internet to see but you're
upset that he looks at you for a second
the comments are right there that Jim's
need to start paying cell phones while
you're working out that's what they need
to do that's part of people stop doing
this [__]
it's so gross well pretty soon you have
men's only and women's only that's what
happens okay
I'm so done with all this [__] I'm so
done oh but since he started exposing
this stuff the people that are on you
know that that got a bunch of likes and
views from that kind of footage they
deleted their accounts yeah entirely
because they're getting so much it's
doing a great job yeah yeah
can you imagine if I were a straight up
thong and my dick was just smuggled in
there like some smoke well if I was the
game and then I was like who's looking
how dare you if I was I'm squatting over
here did you just look at my [__]
they're like yeah dude your [__]
hanging out I'm still not I'm still not
[__] uh over the game when he would
post those pictures of just his
impossibly you bring that up too much
well I mean it's like it makes me
uncomfortable I know but I'm like
anytime we talk about wieners you're
like dude have you seen the games like
you're talking about references if he
walked around if he walked around like
that in a gym I'm still looking at it
yeah
damn I mean it's outrageous well the
girl has giant titties it's like like my
girl get mad if some girl walks in with
like an impossible at impossible ass or
tits It's like a Ferrari poem I mean
it's like okay well well you know the
[__] don't know yeah in fact Dove
said that he's like is this girl's
looking at us he had she had these
possible tits right and he's like uh she
goes you're staring and he goes well you
know if I'm [__] if I enlarge my
balls the size it's like volleyball I
painted a bullseye you might take a
second peek-a-boo honey yeah you know
it's like she goes I got these tits for
me he goes you got an orthopedic pillow
for you yeah yeah those things yeah so
[__] true no you get an Invisalign
for you yeah yeah you know I'm done with
my Invisalign even though I'm wearing
them right now do you have to keep them
in well
for the next three months you got to
wear them at night and sometimes during
the day it's just training the bone you
know training the bone you don't want to
go back I'm done now I'm gonna need you
I'm gonna need you to do something about
your teeth so I talked to him
I'm a liar no you know they called me
and I put them straight to voice message
and I didn't listen but it's on there's
the point let me go ahead and see your
teeth right now you see what's going on
right we see what's going on I see yours
and I'm like
it's all right they're all right really
yeah huh
let me see
how you doing everything the bottom
still jump jumbled up right the Bottom's
still fighting for position the bottom
still a Rugby scrum in the bottom of his
list yeah your bomb's playing smear the
queer right
[Laughter]
that's a [__] up your bottom is fourth
and inches in the super I don't think
your mom's doing quarterback sneak right
they're fighting for position every inch
counts [__]
put them back in
[Applause]
I like it no the top are better though
it's a world of difference oh my God
it's a world of difference
a little Whitener wouldn't kill anybody
well I I did some Whitener I gotta you
did you did it I I bailed A little bit
five days in a row you can't drink
coffee if you do have to sip it through
a straw it's not happening I'm getting
older okay dude just take it I know all
right [__] what else you got you damn it
there we are okay here we go
okay this is really nothing it's just I
saw Frank Mir post this video
and it just made me laugh a lot
because the way he filmed it
and he's talking about something that
already happened in February dad angle
look at you I'll just play for you hold
on
is this just me he can't see I know his
eyes are completely closed
watch The pfl Challenge the series Live
Friday February 10th at 9pm Eastern time
only on fubo Sports Network
I don't know why it just made me laugh
it's actually a great call Frank Frank's
been in so many fights and trained so
much just skin on his face is so thick
and he's getting older so what happens
is you just lose your eyes that's a
fighter space if I've ever seen one you
just can't the sun's just yeah it was
completely closed yeah I was like he's
awesome yeah I love that guy
uh someone sent this in because you know
Brendan and Ferraris but I guess this is
a kid that's 11 three years old
apparently a three-year-old kid I don't
know the details of exactly but he's
driving based off cameras and an iPad
and he's driving this really I got some
sf90 crazy expensive Ferrari right yes
so you can see him driving here oh well
that's really bad
I know so there's a bunch of comments of
like how could you do this and then how
do you let a usual Drive
but then then some people the dad's
controlling it no no
control cars no there's no there's no I
mean I'm sorry I think it's a child's
car that's made to look like a Ferrari
that'd be the best child's car of all
time it's huge right yeah that's a
regular sf90b my thing is like is this
kid really three years old that would be
my thing I don't know I think he's like
that you know like you know yeah yeah I
don't know
kid has some swag though definitely I
mean his dude his dad is rich as [__]
hey miss that may have helped him taught
him how to do that yeah I think I think
dads do that my dad taught me at a young
age to drive yeah put my kids on my lap
and we go around we'll have the area
where we go around but we don't but yeah
if you're not driving by himself he
looks like if you nick that car there's
a problem yeah but he they went on the
road there they're in there yeah you
don't have to worry about cars nothing
but I'd be worried about running my
house it did look like it was stop and
start though a lot right so maybe it
took like a bunch of different yeah
because it was it was fast forwarded and
slow-moted yeah so he might be like hit
the but still I wouldn't trust my kid
not to just floor it and run right in
like Jesus Christ crazy eyes she's a big
daddy scary
um this is a little bit older but this
uh
la clerk I saw this she was able to I
never saw this she was able to take a
knife away from someone guy comes in
just with a giant Hatchet like a huge
which is a very big knife she like rips
away from look at him he's trying to rob
it and take her hostage
like he was gonna stab right in the
stomach she's pretty calm she's like she
grabs the blade she grabs the blade and
then look you should wait look he's like
oh damn then she goes
she says if he ever comes back she told
him if you ever come back I'm gonna kill
you but they can't I don't think they
found them yet
yeah I didn't see any updates on it was
this freaking ass is this a mask what a
loser you can't even rob somebody
like he probably got his car was like
holy [__] dude I can't get this right
but uh he's in a mask
yeah he's he sucks that's the thing that
sucks about Mass she's a badass though
she is a badass it was in Westlake yeah
it's not that far from him he said be
quiet I'm killing if you say something
she was like say what give me the stupid
knife dumbass
uh you talked about dick beaters earlier
this was sent in to us oh this guy is a
giant yeah he's the the arm wrestling
champion he's an arm wrestling guy oh
wow he better be and there's him holding
White Castle burgers
he has some conditions
that's right stop it and grab a White
Castle slider leave that look at his
hands compared to the slider yeah
that's a slider
I've uh I've met somebody like that or
has that he can't even have uh a ring on
there's no rings so you just get to
accept it you just get that dude yeah
it's like Popeye yeah that's it but like
not the cool one right yeah he's got
pretty bad psoriasis and stuff I mean
because I'm sure he has it's on
cardboard some weird condition I don't
know that White Castle's the best thing
for your psoriasis I think that's the
least of his problems
uh there's these YouTubers that were
pranking a Chinese Embassy I guess it
wasn't yeah I was in London did you shot
down no that's very but they got in
trouble for a second because they were
somehow remotely flying above the
embassy right to them they're not doing
anything wrong some people are so smart
I love it this stuff yeah that and it's
going in a weird Direction
and then come out here saying uh
basically like what Russia's doing is
crimes against humanity that's where you
you can see war in the future well they
they you know the Wagner rewards are
long too it's not this thing's nowhere
near being done so try Russia throws all
the bodies at a war so if they have to
lose 500 000 they don't care that's what
they do yeah
yeah
bad news
this might be the last one so this is
just a an update on wow I Am Legend part
two so Michael B Jordan would be in it
as well as Will Smith for an alternate
I'm glad Louis Smith is still working
it's stupid yeah I'm from acting for
slapping I think enough time has passed
by acting I think what it did was uh
like I didn't never thought he'd get
canceled forever I think what it does
though is he was his whole brand was
built on being Mr Cool nice guy yeah and
you saw him at a in a very ugly stage
and I think that's a really hard thing
for him he's aware like there was an
inconsistency there so you go you might
have been lying a little bit about your
well that's why Ellen right like we've
heard of people being [__] before
and it's all good like whatever that's
what they're doing with Alan if your
thing is you're nice all the time be
kind like that's literally her brand be
kind yeah you're dancing like I always
give back and then [__] off you get
offset you're like [__] everybody and
people go oh you're fake yes so I think
with will that like what the [__] but
you said a lapse in judgment thing about
it for was he 50 something years old for
40 years of his life he was Flawless
yeah one bad call on his part yes but
and then you just write them off but but
no but what I'm saying is that it's even
nice people but you know I agree all
what you said I agree but I think when
you when you
um Bank on being flawless
right so so it's all an act yeah because
you know we get a sense also who you
might be when the cameras are not on
yeah because you're human yep you're
just human yep
um that's what can really [__] with your
brand because you built an entire Empire
yeah when people grow your face it's
like find out Tom Hanks is a giant
[__] like what there you go yeah that
was kind of how it was with Ellen right
you're like the lady who dances and [__]
like dude the worst like oh what yeah
and you didn't believe it and then
people start coming out oh man there are
a lot of people that I've like as I get
older they make a [__] load of money a
lot of money but they're [__] well
they they did it the wrong way they did
it they did it they cheated yeah it
never pays it [__] it's gonna it's
gonna get system and it's gonna get you
one or another like I find this out with
people sometimes and I'm like it's with
Comics too right like when you hear a
comic like I don't know any really now
but I won't mention names but it comes
like don't work with that guy he you
steal Joe he should butt me and it's
like that catches up with them oh there
because then once they stop coming hot
then nobody let you do that when you do
spots or nobody wants to work with you
and now you're like oh let me come on
your show and they're like nope yeah
well I know if one uh very successful
comic who I've heard from many very
reliable sources is a straight up Thief
but that person is going to be found out
eventually they have a history of
stealing and I know who you're talking
about yeah that's a that's amazing
people just wait
she I know you're talking about they're
they're waiting they're like they're
like those you know how alligators in
the water yeah and they're just and it's
a lot they're just waiting for it to dip
her toe in and there's a lot of people
yeah who are up and coming and already
in the game and you know not the old guy
those up-and-comers that she that she
treats like [__] well that's not no who
gives a [__] I'm gonna say her name but
if she treats people like [__] those up
and comers eventually become something
with power and then they go oh I don't
need anything from you check this out
you'll see they're already they're
already jokes about it there are yeah
yeah it's like the Bill Cosby thing yeah
forever then finally people go oh no no
that's real I love I love that thing you
don't get away with anything at all
nothing you for a while you will and
then that one I can't wait for for a
variety of personal reasons yeah okay
um
would you okay you drop your own busy
man you dropped the Fizzies nah man my
wallet bro
oh [__] Naked and Afraid contestant
Burns penis on hot cold that was like
that was kind of lame because you don't
yeah whatever so anyways there's a hole
hungry
no you know you you put a fire to the
side to warm up when you're sleeping
yeah so sometimes those coals they pop
oh they want them popped and it landed
apparently on the tip of his penis and
then he had a uh a medic that was a
woman treated yeah she saw let me see
this thing so you feel that you feel
that you called it out of my face
his soldier's little helmet animals
what was it Georgie I lost it somehow
actually around here
oh there we go so Georgie will talk
about this one this is a little bit
older but this is the same guy that was
behind the Logan Paul video with his nft
controversy stuff uh Dylan danis after
that video got posted tried to hop on
and like degrade Logan Paul so the same
guy coffee Zilla went out and tricked
Dylan danis into scamming on purpose
basically
which it's a little bit uh
uh a little bit dirty because coffee
Zilla you put it like in the paperwork
like hey read the paperwork
uh the contract but he hid in the
contract that this is going to be a scam
you're gonna look stupid you're oh and
he just didn't read the contract and
posted and he just went out and posted
it so when he was saying uh post copy
literally spells out scam
yeah but wait so they said Dylan post
this will be yeah we'll pay a thousand
dollars because we are selling this nft
I don't know that he thought he was
scamming anybody he probably was like he
didn't do his due diligence into looking
into it
scam artist he probably was like well
you're gonna give me a grand and the NFC
stuff isn't very like it's confused so
he's probably got that payments out yeah
I'll post it give him a contract he
assumes it's on the up and up you know
that's like a shitty thing to do I think
I I don't know yeah it's definitely a
shady thing you know but that is uh
right Am I Wrong Am I am I off oh no
we're all thinking the same I don't
think Dylan he doesn't know about us he
was scam people on purpose that is
different and then you go after me I'm
all with you but Dylan's just you know
he gets hate for a variety of reasons he
made a gram needed the money you know I
don't know
uh that coffee Zilla does do good work
what did he say in there what did he say
in his uh to check this check this out
that's all he says about I think he was
supposed to leave it up for like 24
hours or something and the website the
website he sent them sent people to like
all the scams that Dylan danis has done
over time before I I don't think maybe
he didn't know there were other crypto
scams that he tweeted out like Dylan
just getting paid and posted he may not
know about I think yeah I was going to
say uh Dylan's he's not a guy it's like
I think Dylan probably isn't deep into
the uh the machinations of what crypto
is and he probably gets paid and he's
like I'll use my platform you guys I'm
up yeah he's just he that's not being a
scam artist that's that's a guy who's
being approached by people he thinks are
legit now hopefully Dylan learned his
lesson yeah don't tell any more money
posting this that's a shitty thing to do
to somebody yes yeah it literally says
we tricked him so that's not cool I mean
you tricked him yeah meaning yeah you
tricked him
okay
don't say he's a scam artist it means
you trick it'd be one thing the album if
he's like we told him this is scam and
we'd pay him a thousand he still posted
checked out this you know but we tricked
him that's funny he's not thinking that
deeply about it he's like who knows
who knows he's gone it's like it's like
doing a commercial like he's not again
you should think deeper about it you
know I understand
but
you know that itching all right last one
just to be on a happy note Bobby his dog
here is has broken the world record for
the oldest dog in the world it's yeah 30
years something over 30 years old but
probably oh no I don't think he's over
30. no he is I thought it was 30 and
some months that's true that's correct
30 year old Portuguese dog expect to see
his 14 12-14 so he's over doubled his
life that's crazy how long that is for
reals though for a dog I know but I
don't know if I believe it no it's true
really yes give us books on Guinness due
diligence yeah that's crazy dude so
that's pretty is it yes
dogs live about 15 years tops mine's 16
which was awesome twice as long 16 gets
hairy yes yeah but to live like
literally it'd be like living 200 years
old that's crazy whatever's going on
with that dog well no it would be 30
times seven those are those are good
[__] what do you mean no I'm saying
the average human the average of a human
lives in 200 years
one year in dog years is seven
yeah I'm just saying it'd be like a
human being if if 16 is worth 210 yeah
it's crazy he looks like [__] that's
crazy not that bad he was walking around
and he's still alive hanging out with
his friends yeah damn
he's had some surgeries though huh who
knows well we can tell by 30 [__]
years and by the way losing your dog
after 30 years is impossible that's like
no you should be grateful do you have
fun
they get [__] cute they grow four
feet you don't have to attack I will
though I'll buy a new tank in six months
once he gets big enough we just gotta
keep him alive till then they're a real
Beast they're sensitive anyway
um the guy goes I go how long is that
fish living but man 12 to 15 years on it
holy [__] that's a long time
how long 15 years you know how long
all the years I'll be 55 when this
[__] house
do you remember when they'd have orange
roughy um yeah yeah you know why they
don't have orange roughy on the menu
anymore
because
um they live over 130 years so a 75 year
old orange roughy is a adolescent check
this out
isn't that crazy
there it is they're cool looking fish
too fish are friends not food
so weird they live forever they're sweet
looking fish yeah
yeah 150 that is crazy isn't that crazy
so they stopped eating because they live
so long yeah
well you're eating them at uh that's a
very old fish there might be a lot of
mercury yeah if it's old
goddamn 150 150 years old dude orange
I don't want to eat 200 years old
they're all so cool looking also how do
they stay alive in the ocean
you know what I mean there's a lot of
animals eat you every fish is bigger and
every fish wants to eat you
wow
is it not sustainable but I stopped
eating tuna Wago you ever seen a real
blue tuna in person
they're [__] cool man and they're
what's that what's that a tuna beef and
tuna like all the you know what I call
them the athletes of the sea yeah yeah
they're fast too all muscle
they're you know they're cool looking
[__] yeah I stopped eating it yeah fish
are friends not food wait it says hey
don't make me mad that's gonna make me
so angry if you start talking about it
did you have fun I still do because it's
over I still do don't and I'm eating all
the fish nope and I'll eat your fish and
I really would I really would I'll kill
you I would really eat your fish and you
know what I would do
good luck in that arowana in your mouth
well how many fish you have now a good
amount and how many of you have died
probably four to five
okay out of like 20. I'm just gonna once
someone got that white ache and it was a
nightmare yeah
the most expensive fish he's ever eaten
yeah well they some are like four or
five grand he waited till he died though
so that's he didn't want to wait so can
I see what was this guy is this guy the
Jeffrey was the long ones right with the
they're in the Amazon and they jump out
of the water so I had to buy a special
lid because it'll jump out there you go
dude that's [__] up don't eat arowana
and that that can't be delicious though
the way it's cooked so if I catch one I
I release it you're a you're not gonna
catch one B
they're good luck too the Chinese think
they're good luck now that one's illegal
do you see the red one no one's illegal
this one's 300K what the f what yeah
like yeah the big ones you're not
getting less than four or five hundred
dollars I have a juvenile one he's eight
inches they're so fun
people going to jail trying to sell them
that's my exact one right there but
they've gone to jail trying to sign up
oh they're illegal the the red ones are
there's red ones that are illegal so
what do you have what color I have a
silver one I have the one Shin just
showed that's a red one right there ah
but those are I have that see that
silver one in the down chin down down in
the middle this one yeah I have that
exact one holy [__]
that's a silver I want to they're dope
they sit at the front and you drop food
and they just they're so aggressive are
they they're sweet they grow two inches
a month two inches a month so I got
about a little I was doing their math I
got about four to six months what's his
name Beanstalk we don't have the name we
don't have a name yet
[Music]
one thing we bring you on fire and kid
is comedy and it never stops and we do
it here and then we do it on the road
too and I get a busy week dude Wednesday
night I'm at The Comedy Store what in
the main room and then I'm in
Bakersfield one night only one show only
Bakersfield is uh February 23rd and we
have 30 tickets left in Bakersfield and
then Pasadena Ice House Is Back shopping
friends me Trevor Wallace Adam Ray
special guest Pasadena California ice
house is back with vengeance and then uh
Sunday we have the Cowboys fight
companion uh we have very special guests
Howie Mandel we have Adam Ray and
another big guest that I will announce
on my social media awesome and then Brea
March 3rd two shows one night only it's
a Friday night in Brea California March
3rd March 4th cow bass fight campaign
for the Jon Jones UFC 285 uh with jelly
roll Rampage a special guests and then
Oklahoma City is March 9th through the
11th Tacoma March 23rd 25th take that
thickboy.com uh and uh come trip
Thursday February 23 24 25. I'm there at
in Edmonton Canada Canada I'll see you
soon Nashville Tennessee Zanies March 2
to the four March two to four Zanies
then Sony Hall March 11th lunch only
doors open 7 30. Brian Callan in New
York City come get some and Levity Live
I'm coming right back to New York West
Nyack New York I'll be at Levity Live
March 16 to 19. hey do me a favor oh and
then I'm at minesfest at the Balkan gas
company April 15th with Tim Poole and uh
um uh Bill ottman and some other people
uh podcasting in Austin Texas it's going
to be amazing hey do me a favor can we
go to yeah that's good actually all
right kids love you all right we're out